la plus récente tornade qui a frappé le
québec mercredi en mauricie a laissé
plusieurs maisons mobiles endommagé vous
le voyez d'ailleurs sur les images les
dégâts ne sont heureusement que
matériels on ne rapporte aucun blessé
aucun décès on a l'impression qu'il ya
de plus en plus de tornades au québec
qu'en est il vraiment on va parler tout
d'abord avec un chasseur de tempête et
nicolas lessard de québec vortix hydro
météo est aussi steeve boily
environnement et changement climatique
canada merci à tous les deux d'être la
première question tout d'abord à nicolas
vous le voyez là c'est lui qui est à
droite
est-ce qu'il faut pas être un peu fou
pour être chasseur de tornades
et oui c'est vraiment le fun de tornades
sa demande sa demande vraiment de faut
être précis dans nos mouvements de
vraiment faut être très très très alerte
sur tout oui parce que ça serait placé
pas toujours comment ça se déplace une
tornade exactement à l'autre au québec
un petit peu plus rares ici c'est
vraiment vivant linéaire les plus
torrentielles et les éclairs
on peut être surpris les éclaircies
parfois proches le sap est surprenant
web alors on pose la question
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya plus de
tornades qu'avant on a l'impression
qu'on n'a plus peut-être parce que c'est
mieux documenter qu'est ce que vous a
passé est abolie mais celle de l'année
dernière mois de septembre
gatineau à l'arc et tout le monde
c'était une des plus puissantes dans les
dernières années puis à s'est produite
en milieu urbain se serait créé sa
marque imagination il y en a eu
plusieurs
dans les dernières années mais les
statistiques même aux états unis où il y
en a beaucoup beaucoup ne montre pas une
augmentation nécessairement mais c'est
vrai que l'échantillon est pas
nécessairement très très loin on les a
touchés des centres urbains c'est un peu
seul donc les a été documentée on a pu
en savoir davantage ici au québec ce
soit
là on prête attention peut-être un petit
peu plus à cause de ce qui est arrivé
l'année dernière
effectivement mais les méthodes pour
détecter les ors les tornades sont pas
prêts pour savoir si c'est parce que
souvent ici au québec qui est pas des
populations partout on regarde il ya des
nouvelles méthodes de regarder les
images satellitaires à 20 après haute
résolution
on peut le savoir si une tornade qui est
passé en plein bois ou personnes la
personne ne l'a vu donc là on en
dénombre plus c'est des méthodes qui
sont sur un peu comme comme on dit
souvent les méthodes sont meilleurs pour
le détecter ce qui en a plus c'est la
question est spécialement des tornades
parfois effectivement les personnes pour
l'avoir f qui n'est jamais détectés mais
effectivement donc car les ingrédients
sont là
nous on pense on peut on peut dire si
une couverture radar à l'endroit où ça
se produit nous on va revoir un peu
comme un tableau de bord on va avoir des
lumières qui vont clignoter puis là
on peut on peut se douter est en tout
cas on voit que la rotation
on ne sait pas si ça touche le sol si la
personne pour nous le dire ce que nous
on a donné des lettres en au delà il y
en a pas plus et est ce qu'elles sont
plus puissantes
je me souviens il a comparé nicolas donc
vous examinez évidemment les tornades du
côté aussi des états unis celle d'ottawa
gatineau qu'on avait vu l'an passé très
très marquant est-ce que ça se compare à
ce qu'on vaut aux états unis celle de
gatineau
oui je confirme le vraiment ça se
compare à ceux qui étaient aux états
unis je pense qu'elle a été classée f3
donc on parle devant de co2 conviendront
par des vents de 175 des x 200 km h
c'est assez violent qu'on a vu des
dégâts de ces catastrophique ça s'est
déroulé aussi dans une zone urbaine donc
c'était vraiment très médiatisé aussi
médecine interne est confiant dans le
bois ça la rage des armes ça fait rien
d'autre mais ne s'insèrent détruit des
maisons
celle ci s comparé à ce qu'on peut voir
définitivement dans des allées long le
vue si ottawa gatineau est ce que c'est
une région qui est propice c'est ce
qu'on peut dire bon là il ya un corridor
qui est en train de se dessiner ou on ne
peut pas le faire
il étudie régions sont plus propices
c'était la dernière de l'année dernière
c'était là il y en a eu au début de
cette année c'était la première de cette
année dans le même secteur ou à peu près
on faisait des blagues avec ça mais
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas dire que c'est
notre tournée doit aller à nous non pas
encore comment ça se forme internet
nicolas attendant tu sais vraiment plus
à des bols à tulle quant à la formation
d'une tornade la plus à la formation la
plus commune c'est vraiment de suspense
et deux par cellule donc tout un courant
ascendant assez puissant puis ce courant
ascendant l'autre commence à tourner à
prendre de notation donc un tourbillon
qui se créent au niveau du sol puis le
c'est là que l'internet qui apparaît
c'est que les conditions pour mettre en
place la chaleur davantage de shalla
lorsqu il fait plus chaud il ya plus de
risques d'avoir notamment
mais si on peut
une super cellule en fait c'est un orage
très puissant soit un orage très
puissant soit d orange organisé puis
pour les orages les recettes pour les
orages cessé de l'instabilité donc la
chaleur au niveau du sol un peu d'air
froid qui passe au dessus
ça ça va créer de l'instabilité mais ça
prend un petit peu plus pour avoir des
tornades
ça prend des toutes les communes
combinaison d'éléments et ça prend aussi
la plupart du temps fait un cisaillement
devint donc les vins qui change en
altitude
donc ça prend des conditions
particulières donc avec des étés plus
chauds ans et le mois de juillet a été
très très très chaud également donc
c'est une des conditions propices à
l'arrivée d'une tornade en poésie oui en
fait les tornades se produisent la
plupart du temps en après-midi en début
de soirée donc un peu le même patron que
pour les orages effectivement très bien
on va poursuivre la discussion tout de
suite après la pause et son